the first episode was great because it
was the most Italian dude of all time
they went to an Italian restaurant with
the most Italian dude of all time
and the lady in it was like
we've had this restaurant for a long
time and you know it was inhabited from
my father Frankie my grandfather Vinnie
died gave it to Frankie and now Frankie
runs it with my husband my father
Frankie runs it with my husband Frankie
they're both in Frankie oh it's Italian
now Frankie comes out he's like yeah
what's going on
and Gordon Ramsay is like this is
terrible
and the Italian guy's like all right
let me ask you a question
like right away hot like in Italian and
I love it dude because that's my family
all right let me ask you a question he
says how big hold on how big is a chip
on your shoulder
and the guy's like me it's a question
how big a chip I gotta be how big of a
chip do I gotta have how big of a chip
should I have my father died I'm feeling
my father every day
how big of a chip left off he's like
listen do you want more up or not and
then he just softens immediately flips
that Italian switch to off which is less
emotional but also more emotional and he
says I needed more to my life
uh
she died
dude it's so funny dude
I love it because he thinks he knows
more than oh dude apparently this is it
and if it's not I'm gonna be very
dramatic Christmas I'm amazed you can
stand up straight the size of the chip
on your shoulder here it is what size
chip should I have let me just saying
what size chip should I have let me just
ask you
dude that's amazing these are the chip
on your shoulder so what size chip
should I have let me just say as a
[__] mic my dad put a million dollars
in the place and I'm failing what chip
do you want on it no two restaurants on
no chip no chip because if you're not in
that fit State of Mind to respect what
little customers you have
you shouldn't be [__] in here
okay it's Italian shut it down walls are
up
I'm gonna give you all the anger I got
I'm Gonna Give You All I ain't got I'm
gonna give it to you in a short amount
of time and after that the wars are
coming up and I'm shut down
you understand me
I blew my [__] ear out over here
that's great it blew it out
that's how that's how I get when I'm
Italian dude when I I'm an Italian I
yell I blew the [__] ear out of the
beach [__] not pill the Beats we have
phones it's all good I hear it on the
right side it's all good and it's all
better it's all better
one Fire fixed it one Higher
okay okay the way the walls went up were
quicker than the [__] Star Wars doors
no chip because if you're not in that
fit State of Mind to respect what little
customers you have
you should be [__] in here
okay period okay I've got a question for
both of you here we go you want my help
yes or no look yes I do
I needed more than my life
ah seen so many movies
life is a movie for this guy
guy watches De Niro movies and you're
like I mean that's me you know I would
do that
lions are where it's at
hey I'm jerk off throwing [__] plates
dude I love it I Feel Home there hey a
[__] jerk off yeah you [__] jerk
off the other guy that's the other guy
a monologue in Streetcar Named Desire
dude I'm [__] stuck here destroying
my family and in the meantime everyone
else is just like look you just serving
veal
just it's not that it's so it's just
like it's as big it's as bad as you make
it I'm stuck here
I'm destroying my family trudest
uncooked veal
my dad gave me a million dollars do you
know what it's like
to fill your fight every day chip on
your shoulders the size of Montana
[__] you I love how Italian [__]
stuck here destroying this is what you
wanted it's my dream I [__] everybody
I live without every day
on
unfucking believable wow
wow I will tell you something here we go
even though it may appear that all of
you have given up maybe I'm bitter cut
them off dude the Italian way the
Italian way even though it seems that
all of you have given up let me ask you
a question Gordon
you can say a lot of things about me I'm
a cheat
I'm a liar
I'm a race car driver and I'm a Card
Collector I also do stamps but one thing
you always can't tell me is I ain't
never giving up
and we're done every day
um oh dude Italian's got to live with
everything every day you know what I
mean God damn it they put the baggage on
them
and I gotta live with that every day I
gotta live with that every day
sir are you you're next I believe
he said Subway
It's just sometimes I get the wrong
bread you know I go home I gotta live
with that every day
sir
I think they're calling you I think it's
your thing that's ready
great I would like an oatmeal cookie as
well please thank you you guys have good
cookies for some reason
dude I gotta live with that every day
I want to go see Dude Where's My Car in
the theater I walk down halfway through
I got to live with that every day or
every day of my life so how big of a
chip on my shoulder am I supposed to
have
believable
well let me tell you something when it
cuts him off even though it may appear
that all of you have given up maybe I'm
bitter hateful and disgusted than it
shows that's what I never gave up that
don't say I did Streetcar Named Desire
dude he's crying here's the thing man
Italians when you call Italian something
they'll [__] tell you three things
that they are but then they'll disagree
with you about the one thing that you
called them
it's the most amazing it is the most
Italian thing you could [__] do
well you [__] lied Vinnie you're
technically Allied I tell you what I may
be a disgusting piece of [__]
I may be 45 pounds over [__] weight
and I may also have taken some flying
lessons but one thing I'm not is a
goddamn Maya
and you're just like just save it Vinnie
two three things right now that I am
that you didn't mention
and then I'm gonna bring it back home
okay I'm gonna talk about the thing that
you said I was just gonna forget about
it I'm gonna bring it back home it's
gonna make it seem like I got more
validity in there well you know when the
pendulum swings you understand
Vinnie Vinnie you're very emotional I
may work part-time at Sea World okay
I may have hair that of a lesbian woke
liberal
okay
and they may not be able to moonwalk for
[__]
but one thing I'm not
is emotional do you understand me
it's disgusting Behavior Vinnie
oh he goes on
with his hands now he
think about at times is just the emotion
scream and then you soften it up you
know
that's like everyone think the Al Pacino
that's the thing that [__] it up
that's the thing that [__] up Italians
is Al Pacino's acting
in The Godfather when she was like when
the when the when the [__] wife of Al
Pacino was good you know she's going to
go in and ask him if he had the the hit
put out on her [__] dad or whatever
it is and she's like did you have the
hip put out on on my dad and he's just
and you think but you know it's gonna be
like oh you [__] oh you don't
ask me oh you don't talk oh you don't
[__] do this and now but you know
sitting on a [__] desk with his hands
in his pockets and takes a long beat and
he says
don't ever ask me about my business Kate
he [__] it up for the rest of the
generations to go
before that Italians were just [__]
screaming everything are you father
every day
here we go it's disgusting Behavior
Vinnie do you have you ever feel your
father every day
did you I'm asking you a question
my father died 20 years ago slammed
Jefferson
to fulfill your father every day I'm
mixing your questions you have a [__]
Jeff
my father has been dead for 20 years
okay I'm very sorry for that because Dad
and Mom mean everything to me if if you
failed your father every day let me say
it the right way would you feel good
about every day go to work would you if
I'm asking you a question trying to take
I like how he's trying to take the
conversation
home with them you understand
uh going Ramsey you think he was going
to ask me something I gotta ask you some
I gotta ask you a few things why you
feel about failing your father huh
and what's that I have no idea it's been
like five six years five or six years
probably because I made two years it was
here before I got in
stay there two seconds what's in this
one
is that
this was from a party everybody wanted
me to save him it's a tilapia cook
tilapia yep
and he brings it back and freezes it is
he seriously asking to put that on the
menu Terry wants me to reuse on my
trauma way behind his back away start
Italian the whole family start time away
I want to try them away
dude throw
yay boy back from a party every time I
go behind his back I trom away dude this
is I cannot believe how [__] Italian
this family is I just cannot believe it
dude there's good they gotta have like
two two three guys named Butch in here
it's unbelievable I want this whole clip
yeah he goes there's nothing wrong with
this which is where some of the
arguments where the argument's thoughts
it says
yeah we go
and then we got then we come this way
there's more no stop you want to [__]
look at this
welcome to [__] hell wow this is a
walking can you smell that Ryan such a
difference
that's reveal how old is that yeah
I don't know how that looks like this
and I don't know how this got in here so
take that [__] thing up so Italian
what is this a dressing that's not the
dressing for today
that is black mold just unreal yeah what
is this monkey
what is this oh that's a that's the
monkey we had from the children's party
I was looking for that actually to be
honest I don't know how it got in here
we we must be [__] Vinny we wanted to
keep it for something
maybe I think what he wanted to do was
cut the legs off and use them as a wish
thing you have a wish on it maybe for
good luck or something like that I
really don't understand Let's go ask
Vinnie hey Vinnie hey Vinnie what are
these monkey Paws for makes a question
I got four monkey balls all right
you calling me what a monkey order
I may be early on in my life an
insurance salesman I may have been a
lightweight training boxer that never
made it and I may have eyebrows that
connect if I don't pluck them well one
thing I'm not is a monkey board
can you smell that yeah I could I could
smell it from here
so dip
hey come here bring that here bring that
here oh my God I said there's something
I said there's something stench of stink
and [__] disgusting a snake the whole
[__] place
oh
take it away
we are [__] wow that is the worst
walking here we go I've ever [__]
witnessed what a dick you have lost
[__] control what a dick I'm getting
[__] out of here what a disc and
you're short help my dad makes these
changes last because it'll happen just
so and you're short did you did you know
that you're too short
can barely reach the [__] dressing
you're a short [__] guy
[Laughter]
like I love it
what is this is the worst walk-in closet
I've ever seen in my [__] life look
at this smell this smells like [__]
the inside of my anus after I haven't
[__] wiped and haven't showered all
day and after I just took a [__] all
right it's absolutely terrible and look
at these peaches over here they're so
bad when you eat them it makes you
literally feel bad about yourself it's
like a mental thing it doesn't even
taste bad just hours later it puts you
in a depression and it makes you feel
like you didn't amount to anything in
your life all right we're out of here
you've got to fix this you're also too
short
you're a short guy
get the keys to my car gets in a [__]
Lambo
you could never afford this
for the restaurant for my family 24
hours for me but
all in all I think I grew up the
Italians just think their whole life is
a movie it's amazing dude